你看黃仁勳最近爆紅
全世界都在說他
哇 整個頭髮都白的
他們都說他這樣帥翻了
沒錯
他回台灣整理頭髮
特地交代設計師說
別染黑
我要看起來
就是這個年紀
該有的樣子
不染黑
反而成為了他的招牌
哈哈哈哈
我也是不染黑的愛好者
老中醫配白髮
就像功夫大師有白鬍子
一看就知道他有歷練
有內功
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
這一集要跟你分享
掉髮多少算正常
它原因是什麼
3食物養回頭髮
1穴位促進生髮
黑髮長回來
白髮真正的問題
就是腎虛血虛
白髮長出來不只是老
還可能是
心血管疾病的預告
歐洲一項針對兩千多人
的研究發現
如果一個人在四十歲前
出現明顯的白髮
他罹患心血管疾病的風險
就是一般人的五倍
白髮不只是老化
更是身體的警訊哦
哇 五倍哦
這樣很高耶
為什麼容易長白頭髮
在中醫的學問裡頭說
白髮常跟這三個原因有關
腎虛 血虛 氣滯
一 腎虛
腎藏精 主骨 生髮
腎是先天之本
很多中醫書裡頭都講
髮為腎之華
我特別舉醫宗金鑑說這句話
說髮為腎之華
這句話是什麼意思呢
就是腎氣足
頭髮就烏黑濃密
腎氣虛
頭髮就變得又細又軟
還變得乾澀 變成枯黃
甚至於提早掉光光
如何知道自己腎虛
你有沒有
腰痠背痛 記憶變差
或晚上一直起來上廁所
那就要注意了
可能就是
腎氣不足 腎虛了
二 血虛
髮為血之餘
血不養髮
毛髮失去光澤容易變白
血虛有什麼症狀呢
臉色蒼白 容易累
手腳冰冷
睡不好還狂掉頭髮
有這樣子的症狀
就是血虛的警訊
血一虛
毛囊就像土地乾燥了
水不夠 黑髮就長不出來
掉髮也就跟著來了
三 氣滯
就是情緒壓力大
肝氣不舒暢
現代人常常
情緒壓抑 壓力大
導致氣機不暢
肝氣鬱結 血行不順
連帶也會影響頭髮
如何知道自己氣滯
常常悶悶不樂
愛嘆氣 胸悶
肋骨兩側 脹痛
女生就會有經期不順的現象
氣鬱久了 不舒暢
頭髮自然沒有光澤
毛囊得不到足夠的養份
髮色就變淡 變白
甚至於掉髮嚴重
每天按1穴
讓頭髮長回來
要想改善掉髮
由白轉黑
來 有一個穴位叫做
頭皮穴
每天捏一捏這個穴
敲一敲頭皮
刺激頭皮的血液循環
幫助你增加頭髮
白髮轉黑髮
那頭皮穴
就是在頭皮上嗎
不是在頭皮上
是在你的耳朵上
耳朵
耳朵的邊緣
這個耳朵
這個叫耳垂對不對
耳垂的邊緣
這個地方就有個穴
叫做頭皮穴
頭皮穴你用右手
按右邊的頭皮穴的時候
你用左手在這裡敲頭皮
那同樣的
你按左邊的頭皮穴的時候
你用右手
在這裡敲一敲頭皮
然後這樣子
一面按一面敲
這裡按了這邊敲
這邊按了這邊敲
就這樣子敲一敲 敲一敲
就可以了
這樣子可以
刺激頭皮的血液循環
並且還活化了毛囊
每次要按多久呢
建議你每天按一次
每次一分鐘
你可以在洗臉之後
或者在追劇的時候
就是你很放鬆的時段
來進行這個按壓跟刺激
長期的刺激頭皮穴
促進頭皮的氣血循環
讓養份更容易進入毛囊
可以有效的
改善白髮和掉髮的問題
每天掉髮多少才算正常
掉髮的原因是什麼
根據美國的皮膚科學會
叫做American Academy of Dermatology
他說我們每一個人的掉髮
假如一天掉個
50到100根
那都算還正常的範圍
掉髮的原因是什麼呢
常見的原因有10個
一 壓力和情緒的因素
二 營養不足
三 生活作息不規律
四 藥物的副作用
五 過度的染燙髮
六 免疫系統失調
七 頭皮感染或皮膚病
八 遺傳基因影響
九 體內荷爾蒙的失調
十 手術或重大疾病的恢復期
三個補腎法寶
補腎烏髮又抗老
吃得對按得勤
只是養髮的基本功
接下來這一步才是真正的
從根本調回來的關鍵
補腎
特別是腎虛型的掉髮白髮
這類型的人呢
就得從補腎來下手
這時候要介紹我們的
補腎黑髮3寶
何首烏 黑芝麻 黑豆
黑色食物能夠入腎經
滋補腎兼顧先天之本
先天之本就是腎
中醫說腎可是先天之本
這三個都是黑色的
黑色的食物
補哪一個臟腑
我知道
補腎
對了
把何首烏加黑芝麻加黑豆這三種
把它磨成粉混合成為
三黑粉
市面上有賣這三黑粉喔
你網搜一下
就可以查得到了
好 這個地方呢
就是三黑粉
這三黑粉呢
你用這個勺子啊
舀它個一勺兩勺
放在你的早餐裡頭
像是豆漿 燕麥片
加個一兩勺進去
然後呢 攪拌攪拌
就可以喝了
晚上呢 喝熱牛奶的時候
也加一點三黑粉
晚上就可以睡得香香的
恢復你的體力
你知道嗎
何首烏
不可以用金屬的材料
去處理它
所以呢 我們在這裡用的時候
是用這個木頭的勺子喔
何首烏 補肝腎養血氣
黑芝麻 補肝腎潤五臟
黑豆 活血排毒養顏抗老
你知道古時候的醫學家啊
李時珍 這位歐巴
怎麼說黑芝麻的嗎
他在本草綱目裡頭說
久服輕身不老 延年神仙
常常吃黑芝麻呢能夠
補肝腎 補腦 補氣
不會老得那麼快
另外呢
我在臨床上也發現到
有些人染了頭髮後
睡眠的品質反而變差了
而且比以前更難入睡
推薦你吃三黑粉試試看
從內來調養體質
很簡單很方便
哇很香耶
我這邊就聞到了
我來試試喝喝看
不行啦
這是我要喝的
你快點好好說了
好好好
觀眾要聽你說話
小編請你幫我準備一杯
我講完了 也要來喝一杯
好
改掉5習慣
拯救髮際線一直退
頭髮一直掉
怎麼辦呢
各位讓我們從日常習慣
拯救髮量越來越少
越來越稀的危機
5個壞習慣絕對別再做
做越多掉越快
1 熬夜晚睡
傷肝傷腎陰血虧
白髮枯髮容易找上你
我自己年輕的時候
為了考中醫
長期的是熬夜讀書
壓力大 腎氣傷得可兇了
那個時候沒有好好保養
再怎麼補也不可能
回到年輕的狀態了
但是還年輕的你
好好保養也許就能恢復喔
2 性行為過度
精氣大虧 腎虛
也會讓頭髮一撮一撮的掉
3 吃太鹹
鹽份太多也會傷腎
髮根脆弱的掉個不停
4 快速減肥
都不吃油這也不行
5 吃太多加工食品
吃生雞蛋蛋白
加工食品
高油高鹽又缺乏營養成份
會讓毛囊老化頭皮發炎
天天吃生蛋白還會抑制
你的生物素
叫做Biotin的吸收
讓髮根沒有營養
髮量在腰斬
雞蛋還是煮熟了吃才好
不要吃生的
防止掉髮增加生髮
3食物養回頭髮
吃什麼能夠防止掉髮
想預防掉髮幫助生髮
補充這三類食物
蛋白質 鋅 鐵
第一類 蛋白質
蛋白質是頭髮生長的基礎
蛋白質食物有哪些
你可以補充
雞肉 雞蛋 牛肉 豬肉 鮭魚
吃素的人
可以吃什麼呢
豆腐 豆漿 毛豆 優格 還有牛奶
都是優質蛋白的來源
缺少蛋白質
可能導致頭髮脆弱容易斷裂
甚至於掉髮
第二類 鋅
穩定毛囊 促進蛋白質合成
推薦這幾個食物
牡蠣 蝦 蛤蜊 魚 牛肉
吃素的人可以吃
南瓜籽 芝麻 腰果 核桃 花生等等
都是補鋅的好選擇
研究發現有圓禿
有雄性禿的人
體內鋅含量普遍都偏低
補鋅可以改善掉髮
讓毛囊活起來
第三類 鐵
幫助頭皮血液的循環
尤其是女性
根據國民營養調查
他說育齡的女性
鐵質普遍都不夠
鐵質不夠頭髮就養不好
頭髮養不好當然就掉髮了
推薦你吃的食物有
豬肝 蛤蜊 紅肉 紅鳳菜
深綠色蔬菜
菠菜 黑芝麻
親愛的粉絲們
我們已經開啟會員頻道了
如果你認同胡醫師推廣中醫
照顧自己健康的理念
歡迎每月小額支持
或成為VIP贊助者
有你同行
我們才能走得更遠
真心感謝你哦